こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
朝から後輩達とやっていまして
今日...
ご飯を一食も食べてません
モンハン楽しいんっすよ
モンハン楽しくてご飯食べる暇もねえし
ちょっとさすがに腹が減りすぎて死にそうだなっていうことで
今日もご飯食べようと思います
最近僕思ったんですよ
納豆うまくね？
納豆って健康にもいい訳じゃないっすか
健康にもいいしおいしいっていったらもう非の打ち所も無いっすわ
ネバネバしてると言えども
僕これ一つで食べる必要は無いと思うんですよ
納豆って何かと何かを組み合わせて
初めて真の力が発揮されるのだと思ってるわけでございまちゅ
お風呂はいりたい
最近僕がハマってるのは
カレーライスを食べてるんですけど
カレーライスに納豆をかけると
うまいねん
うまいねんよ
もうほんまにドン引きしました
ドン引きするぐらい美味しくて
カレーに納豆が合うなら結構何でも合うんじゃね？
説が僕の中に出てきて
限界にお腹が減ってるんで
色んな食べ物を準備しました
結構なんかよく皆さまが食べそうなものを
今回準備したんでちゅけども
全部に納豆をぶっかけて
全部おいしいんじゃないかという
もやしを証明します
納豆はね、あんたのナンバーワンだよ
よくわかんないけど★☆（適当ｗｗ）★☆★☆
これはもやしがありまちゅよ
納豆の時代来まちゅよたぶん
ひとまずちょっとネットで調べた
納豆のおいしい食べ方みなさんに教えるよ！
まずすごいこれはやべーって書いてあったのが
こちら、ごはんですよ
ごはんですよが納豆にかけるとめちゃくちゃおいしい
って話があったので
実際にやってみましょう
正直に納豆混ぜてる暇じゃないんっすよ
モンハンがねえええええもおおおおおおおおお
待ちに待って楽しくて
この夜も
頑張るよ
ちょっとごはんですよかけてみましょう
かけ過ぎてもあれなんだからこれぐらいにしておきましょうか
ごはんですよ乗りました
これたぶんおいしいぞ
じゃ、頂きマックスむらい☆
て！て？て？て！！て？て！て！て？？て！
ひゅーーーーーーーーー！！ｗｗ
美味ーい！！！！！！！！！
絶妙のバランスだよ
えっ？！おいしい！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
一品の食品になってますね
美味
あ、全部食ってもうた
そしてもう一つ、たまごぉぉ
たまごぶっかけたらめちゃくちゃおいしいみたいな
情報がありましたので
試してみましょう
容器のキャパスティーが限界だわ
はいできました
うん。
いただきます
あああん
なるほどね、爽やかな味わいになってました
ちょっとごはんですよがうますぎて
うううううううううううううううん
結局食っちゃうっていうね
もう今でも分かると思うんですけど
なに食ってもおいしいんですよ
ってことは、これをもやし
今は納豆がメインだったんですけど
メインが違うものでそれに納豆を足すと
味付けのスタイルだとどう変化するのか
見ていきましょう
まずはこちら、牛丼
豚丼でしょう？
なんかなんでもトッピングしていい感あるから
たぶんなんでも合うさ
では行きます
いやああああああああああああああ！！！！！！
俺は信じてるよ
納豆も牛丼も信じてる
頂きマックスむらい！！
ててててててててってててててててえててててって！！！！
ぴゅうううううううううううう！！
馬ぁぁｗｗｗｗ
え？待って、マジうまいんだけど
牛丼のおいしさをちゃんと出してみて
納豆のおいしさもちゃんと出した結果
爽やかで食べやすい
ヘルシー路線の牛丼になった気がしました
次はこちら、ナポリタン
ここからちょっと怪しくなってくるんではないでしょうか
ご飯じゃないから
もう麺ですから
日本の方ではない
外国の方をお呼びして今から
日本のおもてなしをするわけですから
果たして、日本の....おもっ.................................
やりましょう！！！！！
合わないと思うんじゃないっすかみなさん
ちゅ♡ちゅ♡ちゅ♡ちゅ♡ちゅ♡
納豆の可能性は無限なんですからね
もーこれやべええだいじょぶかなああ
あんんんんんん
聞いたことない
では、いただきます
次いきましょー
いやあダメなのかな全然おいしくなかった
ぜんぜえええんもおおおおまずうううう
味は合わなかったんっすね
明らかに美味しいって感覚ではなかった
これは違いますね、次
次はこちら、天津飯
ちょっと甘いじゃないっすか天津飯って
この甘味に納豆を
新しい甘みになれるかどうかというのが
ポイントでございまちゅ
これは多分合ってると思う
いただきまっくすむらい
ててててててえててっててえっててててててｔ！！！！
ぴゅううううーーーーう！！！
ふーーーーーーーーーーーーう
日本と中華のマッチングでめっちゃ美味しいと思ったんですけど
予想以上にまずかった★
これ俺の見方が間違ってなければ
割とまずいっすよ
次はこちら
ときたら最後はもちろんUSA
納豆の甘さを知らしめてやいらいぜ
納豆チーズバーガーです
では食べていきましょう
いただきます
♪( ´▽｀)
♪( ´θ｀)ノ
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑の↑漢↓字↓
[糵]み↓ん↓な↓で↑　お↑ぼ↑え↑ま↓しょー↓
[艹𠂤辛米]こ↓れ↓ら↓を↑　ちゃ↓ん↓と↓　合↓〜↑わ↓せ↑て↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！糵っ！♬
だめか
グッドボタン押してね！
ええええええええ納豆はねええええ
合わないのでは合わないっすね
いけると思ったんすよだって
カレーに合うって言ったから
インドと相性いいわけでしょう
インドと相性よかったらそれも
ヨーロッパも中華もUSAも全部
いけると思ったんですけども
全然ダメでした
今回の結果でわかったこと
ごはんですよと納豆は最高にうまい！
ずずずずずずずうずずずううううずｚ１１１！！！！！！！！